what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back joined by Sally lemonade
all the way in the heart of the Empire State
Building how are you Sally I am great that's
great I love how you saying so I have to sing
oh yeah yeah yeah no no it's a great time
we gotta have a back and forth you know how
this goes report what are we finally concluding
today we are finally concluding with the Pitch
Perfect Trilogy which I might add so far has
been Pitch Perfect so let's not ruin it let's
temper our expectations I've heard a lot of
people say it's the least strong one first
one still my favorite out of the two we've
watched so far low expectations which means
we might be pleasantly surprised that's that's
all we need right now is to be pleasantly
surprised and what would pleasantly surprise
us is if you leave a like on this video please
go ahead and do that also go check out Sally
laminamanakos Channel she is really pushing
to get her Spider-Man short film done spend
a hundred thousand dollars half of that payment
for it comes from these Pitch Perfect videos
so much money she is on track right now but
guys go support her on YouTube and as always
if you want to catch our full-length reaction
where you can sync up with your own copy of
Pitch Perfect that is available for a super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page covers
so many things exclusively over there and
thank you to all have been joining we've been
a lot of pledges so far because we've been
covering so much Sally are you ready to get
your hormone Harmon I tried doing something
there do you see it your harm off like harmonizing
yeah I try I see it wasn't working
[Music]
is is this an action going International Greg
007 coming to join [Music] what is going on
right now
it's getting late oh my God yes
I just want to sing along but it'll be off
sync [Music]
oh Aubrey's just back with them okay okay
[Music]
I love this song so much this was a strong
opening song [Music] whoa
[Music] [Applause] were they being held captive
is this like a movie that they're in or something
there's no way
[Music] what is happening they must have been
being held captive hey they got our attention
man titties is your sound equipment you're
in the danger zone we have security and I
carry mace cling to you like mom jeans to
a camel toe jeez [Music] is that wait Eminem
this is my song and I feel like y'all should
play my mix
this is embarrassing man it's my job to make
you the best little pimple that you can be
a little pimple little pimple he didn't make
a pop hit all right nicely done so thank you
what I mean is what you gave me was a steaming
pile of pimp well Becca it's on her period
wow oh my God Shark Week it's nasty it's our
job bruh we're producers we bring his vision
to life
I finally quit my job and I'm free free I'm
never going back to that job again it's the
best day of my life I mean I can't be a music
producer without Integrity she's no longer
with her boyfriend clearly because she finally
got her dream job but then quit you go back
together with Jesse no you know the long distance
thing didn't work he lives 20 000 miles away
with his girlfriend and their cat ah Jesse
I quit my job he got fired oh come on I quit
you're kind of making it worse but let this
negative energy be released seriously open
your legs they'll come out no no she's so
gross yeah you need to pay the rent yeah you
could get a job you know you're in shock you
need something to eat [Music] hey Chloe why
aren't you guys ready they all live together
what did you wear that to work yeah underneath
my scrubs Oh I thought I'd never see that
outfit again God tonight is you know Bella's
reunion at the Brooklyn aquarium hello that's
tonight yes oh you know what I will take it
what happened she got fired today [Music]
[Applause] [Music]
I'm gonna say that now every time I see you
thank you so much for inviting us of course
so what do you want us to sing tonight a little
who run the world it's bulletproof you didn't
tell us what the crowd was but I um
call backs we invited you to watch us sing
ooh that hurts that was a major miscommunication
I just thought you guys were so busy with
your your awesome jobs an amazing life
[Music] oh my God their lives aren't amazing
no no they're like having to work real jobs
Fat Amy Winehouse you know you've got these
great jobs right I have one of those yeah
what a bunch of lying pitches could dress
up to get up but guess what I'm never gonna
be that girl who's living in a Barbie world
God I love these musical numbers really does
something for me nipple chubs really this
works every time
[Music] you're all old now [Music] you're
so bright and shiny they look like they was
all breastfed [Music]
[Applause] [Music]
God I love Haley Steinfeld she's so good [Music]
what a cool backdrop to perform to yeah those
fish are probably like what is happening yeah
a toast to the most amazing group of women
I have ever known I would do anything to sing
with you guys again okay okay I've mentioned
that my dad is in the Army and like basically
killed Osama Bin Laden right and every year
the Uso puts on this performance to entertain
and support the troops and this year DJ Khaled
is hosting no cool what if I could get us
an invite to sing No to run military dark
Ops yes of course you're disappointed yeah
sing together again and maybe I'll see my
dad or maybe I won't you know because he has
something really important to do or maybe
I'll be the most important thing in his life
this time oh God can you fly when you're eight
months pregnant what no um no way do you guys
even notice no we saw you in a shot the actress
is gonna get cut from the rest of the movie
who wrote that wow do you know who the father
is
character continues so I guess Emily you're
in was I not always in um
man these two need to find a life knocking
them this documentary is happening we're making
a beautiful documentary in fact we got to
set up where are we going to set up John straight
ahead
okay oh I like this movie oh cue the pony
song two important things to know before we
begin
uh first up is a sound check if they have
you back to the hotel by 1430 back here for
the Big Show at 1700. 1700 is that like later
than the night it's five okay whatever
so on the tour we've got three bands over
here we got saddle up this is Young sparrow
and DJ Dragon nuts and behind me is ever moist
oh ever moist ever moist my man social anxiety
when he's not behind the turntable it's kind
of crazy so be easy huh hello
[Music]
I could be obesity is that Ruby Rose you're
wondering yeah it has nothing to do with the
nationally televised salute to the Troops
special where DJ Khaled is going to pick one
group to open for him at the end of this tour
that was a lot of exposition nicely done just
to call it out you guys are seeing other people's
songs right like the cover band uh actually
Emily writes original songs for the Bellas
I mean I don't really do it anymore hey shut
up get with the program and it was one of
your dads who gave you this spot on the tour
right they just don't like showing the spotlight
so they're trying to intimidate us a riff
off
always there has to be one okay I feel like
this is going to be really embarrassing
[Music] I'm coming up
[Music] so you dare look back just keep your
eyes on me [Music] dance with me
[Music] DJ Cal it's not even watching [Music]
oh [Applause] my Bella Sam [Music] they could
just swing into this can't they hell yeah
we just took the last word of the old song
and matched it with the first word the new
song but you stay on Tempo stay on beat stay
on pitch and of course keep it in the relative
key that was great that was really well done
okay okay so condescending artist s know we're
Jewish what
oh they are acapelling
[Music]
oh they know their Jews and she has a cross
on her ears
[Music] what I'll go logo okay
cool
night call me [Laughter] I mean they're they're
banding together [Music]
oh oh Chicago likes what he sees he's so cute
[Applause] [Music] [Laughter] what even just
for a day okay you guys aren't even in it
Beyonce could be Jewish wait Ariana Grande's
Jewish this is Beyonce no the other one Loved
Me Harder was Ariana Grande zombie apocalypse
[Music] a child is lonely taken
of course this is what you come up with whether
you think of the zombie apocalypse I wouldn't
have come up with this song [Music]
it's pretty cool cover not gonna lie yeah
[Music] let's go
they have some serious competition [Music]
[Applause] [Music] is this a zombie apocalypse
I mean I guess someone would be throwing a
grenade a zombie maybe the category is just
a kickoff point
s the taking off of the sunglasses [Music]
yeah this is pretty awesome yeah this is awesome
we want fellas are doing what they do best
quitting [Music] John Lithgow that's the fuzzy
hair man we saw in the beginning Emily is
it true what you said back there are you really
not writing anymore not right now anyway I've
got 21 credits that I'm taking this semester
the GRE is coming up right around the corner
who cares right I'm actually from Georgia
why are you here long story short I was in
the NG but my CEO recommended me for OCS after
AIT I came OPC
Swoon meet every guy that shows me attention
dogs I love dogs animals are cute you're cute
I mean what what about you me just just let
that compliment slide
I like I love love I love being committed
to love not to you but to like I love um like
orange oh my God such an off put so off-putting
look she's just nervous Greg it's desperate
Sally then I'm desperate because I do that
so what's the plan I really think we should
just drink stay true to ourselves and it will
all figure itself out we have a very stupid
person
foreign
[Music]
I mean in the beginning I was like it's someone's
dad but then it wasn't but now it is so [Music]
what someone's gonna be messing with them
wrote a spade here we go girl don't give me
away [Music] so they do covers too does everyone
just do covers oh most rappers sample and
do covers anyway but I'm wondering if this
was made for the movie or if it's already
a song I saw you do the sound check um yeah
the rip-off thing yeah I don't know why we
keep challenging people to those we we don't
ever actually win oh
no I I work with music Executives and they
they don't look like you ow they suck I'm
a music producer I'm sort of freelancing right
now and I sing for fun people leave it open
for DJ Khaled in the end just tell him that
you sing for fun I'm gonna go now I'll see
you later but I'll be watching good luck that
was painful to watch I bet he's sleazy I bet
he is part of the mob I bet he's part of a
criminal organization yes I think so too Greg
calling it
all these women are fawning over so many guys
[Applause] [Music] ever moist who came up
with that name does anyone have an Ever moist
tell it my grandma's in a band right now never
moist
[Music]
[Applause] [Music] how do you compete with
actual instruments you have to use your voice
as an instrument Gregory but yeah that's that's
gonna be hard yeah okay so they're pretty
and Polished and sexy and like I don't know
I was just listing stuff and I'm sad God damn
you DJ Khaled stop nodding DJ khaled's nodding
oh no not the Khalid nod
[Applause] away I shouldn't be clapping we
are ever most what a seductive name but I
kind of hate the word moist everyone hates
the word noise yeah I don't know anyone that's
like Yay moist is my favorite word in acapella
group with a few YouTube clicks cheers what's
wrong with this crowd you guys have no idea
how great they are Hello Kitty girl girl
oh that sounds great catchy song Come On [Music]
hell yeah [Music] come on crowd you know this
shit's awesome
foreign [Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's
awesome that's awesome [Music] he keeps eyeing
just her yep I can't tell if he's evil or
not though I feel like he just wants her but
not the Bellas yeah
[Music] wow that's that my friend was Taps
from the back of the house it's to honor Fallen
Soldiers
look at this they look like idiots this is
the best thing for the movie [Laughter] if
we had bass then we wouldn't need me and we're
still not clear why Jessica and Ashley are
even here did they just say our names don't
be stupid [Laughter]
you just suck balls in front of DJ Khaled
okay I say we all get up we get dressed we
go over there and we show him that we are
not a joke so like seduce him like what are
you talking about I bet it all I'm 21. this
is just like James Bond Casino Royale
oh there's the bag and that was sunshine [Applause]
oh it's our father still a bad guy so weird
I don't know what's happening why are we hiding
I don't know oh my gosh they're bringing back
their gay moment what is this about what are
you guys doing nothing this should have just
made it happen
maybe that's a Twist at the end Greg what
are the time you smuggle drugs into bounce
a lot and I had to see him get
this is not beside the story I was expecting
in this movie yeah
did you even find me I'm where you've been
for years your crotch was shown all over a
news station so it's not really a
tell us some time away
that would just make me run faster [Laughter]
they just let this crazy guy start singing
yeah and they are playing the instruments
to him you want to give it a go no no possibly
this it has a little Loop going
work your magic they missed the part where
his chest inside an NCAA they could just steal
this from her or she could steal it from DJ
Khaled [Music]
this sounds just like DJ Khaled I go to uh
Khalid oh okay [Music] isn't she amazing American
woman they're the best ones buy them an Englishman
or otter in general oh my God so you were
just with aubry's Dad I'm so excited to see
your show it's just too bad that it can't
make it son of a [__] expect finite disappointment
and remember there's always more
yes release the bees
[Applause] Brothers
[Music] there's some soundproof headphones
[Music]
how do you know it's the bells how did you
know it was the Bellas everything's the pillows
the baby
wow look at the mice what's her name Baby
Fat Amy or Baby Fat Patricia you can choose
her name's gonna be Bella I named her Bella
oh you called it Sally let's go Bella is on
my shirt ciao Bellas who wants to go to Italy
oh me four countries in four days and then
DJ Khaled will announce the winner When we
arrive in France [Applause] [Music] yo these
outfits are on points they really are whole
movie [Music]
everyone looks pretty hot in those outfits
yeah but specifically Anna Kendrick that's
why the British guy wants her [Music]
yeah [Music] cool way to honor the troops
[Music] it really sounds like there's an instrument
she went hard with that one um [Music] I wonder
if they'll sing like God Bless the USA or
something it must be kind of lonely always
being away from your family but in the Army
is kind of like having a second family yeah
of course you know when it's over you go your
separate ways but you're always going to be
there for each other right they're like the
army
what do you mean at no I just don't recognize
the actor but he's really cute well DJ Khaled
wants to meet you how beautiful oh thank you
so nice need a drink Rebecca ASAP have a seat
make yourself a home I'm just waiting for
him to say DJ Khaled I want you to open up
for me tomorrow night Becca DJ Khaled yes
there it is that is great you are not going
to regret this I the fellas are gonna die
can I go tell them I I think you misunderstood
it's just you babe he doesn't want the ballots
we won you take the opportunity I can tell
that you was just playing around I see I seen
something I heard something then I felt something
a heart attack
[Music] but I'm part of a group and we all
have something special there's usually one
who goes off on their own you're the hairy
styles you've really gone as far as you can
with the girls it's time for you to now flourish
on your own independent like Beyonce like
Justin Timberlake come with me a second bless
up [Laughter]
bless up we're talking about my family I'm
I'm not interested tough decision I get no
it's not what do you mean the last movie you
wanted to ditch him to have time to change
she's grown geez Sally pay attention I really
am sorry
he's still playing the piano
what if I we leave tonight tomorrow is like
the big televised event with DJ Khaled and
they're definitely going to pick the Bellas
to perform so oh no he's on the hunt he has
to get out a Caribbean tour you ever been
to Martinique the Cayman Islands yep he's
fleeing she's figuring it out hello know exactly
what's in the Cayman Island that bank account
the mum set up for me on my 13th birthday
she said it was just a bit of an allowance
but I know she didn't want me to ever need
your dirty money what is this movie 180 million
oh my God am I gonna learn to open my
mind get the money this man bothering you
yes he is yeah sir step away from the Bella
could he get any harder goodbye circus
I feel like we've just been shouting at this
movie this whole time I know I'm sorry I was
trying to add to I have to feel like I'm doing
the same thing what I feel like I've been
doing the same thing
[Music] we're liven it up a little
we got ghost sent me to take you to the Uso
reception Chicago never mentioned this man
is full of [__] yeah he's gonna kidnap
them we need to find our friends Becca and
fat Amy right oh they are already there let's
not keep this handsome French man waiting
these women are so weak for the men men make
us dumb Greg you should see what woman do
to men what do we do we never mind [Music]
there's always room for another musical number
right maybe
kind of scared yeah I would be wrapping myself
right now
I'm floating they're on a boat I would be
so afraid yeah that they're just gonna like
drown us
use your heels break
the window
foreign
swim with the fishies hey Amy um I need to
talk to you about something that's kind of
important I had just a sec I'm on a call okay
[Laughter]
what are we doing why are we not calling the
police or Chicago is my time and if my dad's
season he'll take off this is serious Bellows
could really get hurt not on my watch Amy
come on she's surprisingly calm about this
Anna Kendrick yeah
10 minutes ladies guys you know what we should
do where did you come from I've been here
the whole time I'm just small me if we only
have 10 minutes left then sing one more song
baby can't see [Music] this is so weird [Music]
I am admittedly very amused by what's happening
okay
you act like she's human
this just turned into John by four
this is exactly John Wick for
what is happening I'm just glad they're really
committed to this yeah yeah I expect nothing
less [Music]
Patricia okay all my former jelly wrestling
coach slash babysitter what is this so much
[Laughter] [Music]
nunchucks skills let's go this isn't doing
too bad actually [Music]
whoa oh my gosh
[Music]
[Music] yes this is like The Fat Amy movie
to be honest oh my God I don't know how this
movie came to be this way you're living for
it I'm sober I'm so here for it right now
[Applause] [Music] meanwhile Hey DJ Khaled
just wants me to join
God we're alive um DJ Khaled and his team
they didn't pick the Bell as they picked Becca
but I said no because I feel exactly how you
feel you guys are family and you don't walk
away from family okay you can't say no you've
got to do it oh they're gonna be like listen
we almost died follow your dreams I kind of
feel like I've been saying something did that
affect the entire oh my God Emily [Laughter]
a music career would interfere with my business
so tiny Jewish truck you work at the jew struck
I own and just secured Capital to franchise
congratulations cool beans what what finally
left my body what I'm Esther
any questions I think it's time that we go
in with the next chapter of Our Lives you
this is so funny oh you like it their words
Greg you just get out there and you crush
it she loves her don't forget
[Music] oh how wholesome oh they were so supportive
I don't know if I I feel like I'd be a tad
jealous well they don't have a YouTube channel
Greg they should be jealous of you
are they gonna do the DJ Khaled song is there
like a famous song from this uh I don't know
I introduce you to Becca Mitchell you only
get one shot one opportunity
[Music] it's gonna end with a solo performance
that's interesting well the first movie was
like centered around her so it's kind of cool
full circle heaven knows I was just a young
boy didn't know what I wanted to be I was
every little hungry school girl's pride and
joy and I guess it was enough for me God and
I love her voice I think there's something
you should know
does DJ Khaled know about this
I don't know record jail canceled [Music]
[Music] [Applause] can they hear her they
don't have mics probably not
oh
[Music] they have instruments now you can't
hear the acapella group over the instruments
oh John Wick was playing guitar did you see
it [Music]
this is so sweet
[Music] I'm Gonna Miss This trilogy [Music]
foreign that made me cry a little bit it hits
harder knowing it's the last movie [Music]
[Applause]
that's really sweet those look like real tears
I wonder if that was like the last day of
filming or something that'd be great you got
all that on camera right John sure I did all
right because the red light was not on so
I just had to ask
everyone's nightmare that shoots things guys
it's like my dad always says always give a
hundred percent unless you're donating blood
he's gonna be there
the cheese is real
wow you smell like Skittles kind of Taste
the rainbow you can definitely taste them
oh
living a dream oh oh that's nice
it's just us it's always been just us this
is so uncomfortable Gail
I love you
I wonder if he ad-libbed that just for that
reaction that's funny [Music] oh memories
memories
[Music] what the [__] can she really do
that okay I don't know [Music] the mermaid
uh what what was that what where's that friendship
I feel like they just probably shot a lot
more and then they just didn't use it [Music]
cup
is it so transcending nice [Laughter] okay
all over that to me too even though it's not
too many shallow me I know yeah I didn't actually
hear you say that and then as I was watching
the scene go and I was like this guy looks
like Timothy Charlemagne yeah I wonder if
Sally was trying to say he looked like Timothy
that is
really in my head the whole time um yeah you
know people really downplayed this one and
can I pause it why because
and can you hear it yes you can still hear
it I've lowered it no I know right now that's
hilarious we'll suck it up okay I'll just
I'll turn it down [Laughter] uh yeah people
were um saying how it was you know like the
weakest of the three and I don't know I kind
of loved it or something I don't know how
to describe it like it's I don't know if it
was necessarily the weakest but it was definitely
the most different out of the three so maybe
maybe people just didn't like it because I
expected something else and they took a lot
like a few of the characters out of it like
Ben Platt wasn't in it the original Jesse
wasn't I keep forgetting the actor's name
there were just different characters so it
was strange because when they got to the scene
on the when they get kidnapped and they're
on the boat for some reason because that that
surprisingly was working so well for me because
of how committed they were like you love action
movies so this is probably because it was
like a parody action yeah I mean beyond that
it was it was such a left-field choice even
though they try to setting you up like I get
why they do the beginning because it would
just feel like maybe too jarring if they didn't
yeah at the beginning um but the the fact
that that actually worked for just how because
they were so committed to it that it was so
strange and then first it started making the
rest of the movie that came prior to it really
it all started clicking for me like how weird
this one is yeah and then by the time and
like they get to the end when they're all
like that I thought the comedy was just working
so well when they're all gathered and you
find out they all find out that you know that
last scene was very strong between all of
them yeah you know they're all at the table
and they're like yeah of course we want you
to have this career just how supportive loving
they are they're like oh the devil's left
my body my name is Esther that was amazing
it just made suddenly there's a whole movie
just clicked for me in that moment and it
started to really work because yeah the leading
prior to it it was it was a little it was
like I was really I was enjoying it um but
then the strangeness of this whole film started
to really sing no pun intended uh and then
by the end I thought it was really just that
active uh willingness share the spotlight
and love uh really was very very touching
something I would never do in a million years
that part yeah because you're like my ego's
too big like I couldn't do that um it's about
me it's about me let me just talk Sally just
listen to me I'm just gonna remove you from
the video when people don't let me know no
please
Greg now let's say
these are they're very noise canceling I'm
gonna stop yelling and take these off of it
what I was gonna say was this movie probably
home for a lot of people maybe it did a little
bit for me but the writer strike stuff going
on because it's like all these girls had this
dream of being big singers and then as I got
older and started like real jobs then they
realized it had different passions now and
wanted to pursue you know more I guess realistic
uh passions and features so that part was
really um hitting home for me a little bit
but I almost wish I really really wish that
they would have hid the fact that this guy
was her dad and was related to Fatima until
the very end like that would have been a mic
drop thing for me but like you knowing the
whole time that this was how it was gonna
happen like they didn't really leave that
mystery for the ending once he realized he
uh he's a bad guy and that he's her father
but other than yeah you know what I mean I
wish they they didn't yet tease him at the
beginning and and I wish they they cut it
once she burst through the window and started
spraying the fire hydrant uh the fire hydrant
uh the oh my God what the hell is this called
um at first I was like wait it is a fire just
like I don't know why I thought fire extinguisher
yeah yeah yeah Jesus we both were like yeah
she brought a fire hydrant um yeah she started
spraying the I think then you that's when
you could have ended it right there because
you already have seen I think you gave away
too much yeah with the explosion I agree get
away yeah I thought they gave it away a little
too much um but yeah you actually bring up
an interesting point that yeah that's a really
interesting point because normally it's Hollywood
and these movies will end especially after
like three movies of acapella career of yeah
they all become like a successful band or
singers or whatever you know they that's normally
the direction it would go so there is something
relatable and poignant about most of them
and like ending on a note of no I'm gonna
go to this career path and I'm okay with that
I'm happy with that and this is a part of
my past and it's something on the lowest treasure
instead of being like I have to it has to
be this or I'm a failure in life you know
yeah I think that was actually a really a
really meaningful thing to do especially because
you have like other people like um Anna Kendrick
who's able to have her actual she gets to
have the career and then on an open open ending
for Haley Steinfeld as like she's going to
continue to write but we don't know what will
become of her career and I thought that was
very full circle because the beginning I remember
one of the issues we had with the second movie
was that we felt like uh Becca was kind of
pushed to the side and she originally started
as like the main focus of the first movie
so I felt like with this one what I liked
about it was that it brought back Becca being
kind of the main focus at the end yes and
I also really loved her and Fat Amy teaming
up together at the end because they were always
kind of like the stronger Duo I would say
so and also her just randomly hating on hailee
Steinfeld the whole movie was like such a
weird but awesome like running joke at the
end like oh my God shut up yes we're Fat Amy
didn't become funny to me until she threatened
her dad on the phone with the call that was
amazing that when she started that and then
like everything she was doing after that was
like really funny that would be the Oscar
clip you know what I mean yeah
but yeah this one definitely like the the
last one becomes more heightened um a little
bit more zany and wacky a little more cartoony
and this one I felt like they were just fully
embraced uh the hijinks of it without sacrificing
the heart like it's not it's not perfect by
any stretch you know despite that fact that
it's in the title it's by no means perfect
uh like they got a lot of repeat beats in
the previous one I was gonna say I can see
how like some people probably just didn't
like it because you're right there was some
repetitive things about this movie and also
the tone was just so different from the other
two which I didn't mind it because I think
it was still an enjoyable movie to watch but
like I can see how people probably just was
expecting the tone to be the same and expecting
those big raunchy jokes and just weird which
they still had like sprinkles of it in but
like overall this was still a more I would
say cheesy movie in comparison oh totally
well it seemed like they had a Pitch Perfect
3 script for another competition and then
somewhere down the line someone said America
this is too real America Happy Father's Day
they said this is too repetitive it's just
the same plot again of them competing against
this [__] you know band like it was just
the same thing again what if we throw in this
thing with fat Amy and let's just make some
wacky [__] I was just thinking you really
mix it up when you set up the pitch meeting
where they're just like what if yeah but what
if we take this other screenplay I have it's
not fighting just smash them together give
this to Fat Amy about a woman who ran away
from her dad and she's coming back in her
life it really seems like they suddenly had
this like crazy I was so fascinated to know
how this came to be because I could totally
see people not liking this movie for the exact
thing that I really ended up surprisingly
enjoying which was that whole last like 20
minutes of this film which I could totally
see people completely checking out and going
too much too cartoony and of course I would
never slight someone for feeling that way
I would be like I would never be like you
just don't get it I totally understand if
you don't like it uh but for me it happened
it was so weird here but because of how confident
they were in doing it it worked for me it's
the action that did it for great guys like
had there been no action and he really it
sucked but but it was it was the action that's
what gets you Greg yeah so yeah you just need
action uh I was also gonna say that okay so
like the first one was so raunchy kind of
reminded me of like a female I won't I won't
say super bad because I'll get hate for that
but you know what I mean like kind of like
a raunchy like female movie which isn't um
done a lot I guess Mean Girls is kind of that
and so with this one it kind of reminded me
of like a Disney Channel movie like what's
this new cuss words in there so that was different
and I kind of I had the idea my idea listen
guys I should work in Hollywood because my
idea was that they would like I thought I
called it in the other movie that they'd go
on tour but I thought it'd be more like a
they'd be touring kind of like rock and roll
style like going to City to city and then
um they're being like crazy like hangover
plots going on which that's kind of what I
was expecting given you know the tone of the
others but then um I halfway through I was
like this is too cheesy for me in like Disney
Channel but then it redeemed itself for me
with with the action uh parodies at the end
and then the that one conversation they all
had together kind of like tied it all together
for me so that's how I feel about it I I hear
what you mean like there there's a there's
a quality to it that doesn't quite feel it
kind of feels like and I know this is not
the case this was released in the theaters
a couple years after Pitch Perfect Two like
a TV movie is that what you're gonna say it
kind of feels like when Disney plus goes we're
gonna do a sequel finally to something and
they bring back the cast and everything and
then it's like kind of weird like yeah this
is sort of that yeah it has that it has that
touch I wonder what the Gap was between the
second movie and this movie because that you're
right it does kind of feel like that like
2017 was this one and Pitch Perfect Two released
hopefully autocorrect because I can't see
it was 2015. so literally two years apart
it just has that Vibe it does um that of like
something soft but I like reunion pandering
I like the riff-off scene here more than the
second I mean the first one's the best I agree
hands out hands down first one is the best
uh the second one like I don't think I don't
remember it I remember it before the setting
of it but I remember because it was distracting
and how it it didn't sound real and not like
this one doesn't and what I mean by that is
like you can tell they're like in a recording
booth doing it this time versus the first
one felt like they were really on the street
doing it yeah and uh this one I love that
they embraced the how it turned into like
a community aspect and all the instruments
and the mixing and stuff and the mixing of
the different genres was cool you got country
you have rock you had rap or r b and then
Pop I actually thought that was really cool
yeah they did that very well the only critique
I have like filmmaker critique about it is
they were in this big hangar and there was
no like Reverb there was no Echo and that
would have just been such a cool I guess audio
uh effect to have for that sequence would
have been cool I mean yeah they they started
sacrificing that I think in the in the second
movies is that where people would download
these tracks [__] like that yeah it's
realistic touches um yeah I mean some of the
com there's a lot of like flat jokes in here
there's a lot of Comedy that is like there
it becomes it becomes so sick commie you know
where they're like what is the funny thing
about that person from last movie okay let's
just do that joke a bunch uh yeah it wasn't
as shy time like I feel like the jokes in
the first movie The reason why it was so funny
to us is a lot of it was like shocking like
you weren't expecting it and in this movie
I felt like they were all kind of like predictable
jokes not all of them but but a lot of them
it turned it turned them into sitcom characters
a lot of them don't feel like a real character
but when it got to the finale all that started
making sense to me for the kind of Comedy
this was where it it went to like an like
an Anchorman level kind of Comedy or like
a Will Ferrell type of Comedy uh is is is
yeah this kind of like becomes a little more
sketch comedy-ish yes this one I would agree
with that yeah and then the yeah because there's
a lot of like they they keep the girls obsessed
with guys I like that Anna Kendrick didn't
end up with that one dude um yeah he eliminated
the romance of that because that would have
been annoying repeat beat um yeah no it's
it's not I thought he was gonna be evil too
so did I he comes across like he is just looking
so yeah this movie has a terrible critic score
and terrible audience score oh my God it's
nowhere near fresh as an audience score 43
percent and uh critics scores 28 all right
so you know I will gladly embrace the fact
that I really you know what I like surprise
on the second one I liked it better than the
second one yeah
I was just about to say I like it more than
the second one I I had more I had and maybe
because it might have something to do with
the fact that we love the first one and then
the second one was like oh okay it was as
good as the first one and and then this one
people are like it's not good so we go later
I'm like I don't know I would re-watch this
one I don't I wouldn't re-watch the second
one to be honest there was nothing about it
that I was like oh yeah I surprisingly don't
remember that much about the second one me
either me either that's how I know the movie
like at the times I watch a movie I'm like
oh it's decent but like if if I know it's
like bad to me like it's usually because I
won't remember anything about it well I love
what I what did I like I loved when they did
embrace the the heightened qualities of the
second one a lot like when they went when
um when Fat Amy's like rowing to come back
no that scene sticks out to me because we
were dying during that scene yeah um but I
remember that movie just being feeling so
long I think that's I think that's why it's
a long movie it was a very long this one was
more digestible being a typical hour and a
half yeah so because they they set you up
for we're we're gonna pretty much do a lot
of the same tropes we've established in the
last two like with Ruby Rose and her band
like the competitive one they just totally
dropped that shot I know yeah I forgot about
them until until the end when they're in the
audience I was like oh wait yeah they were
supposed they replaced all that run time with
this weird Fat Amy storyline and uh I could
have done without that scene between them
you know what I'm talking about when they
like meet up and she's like so excited and
then he's like I don't know if I'm gonna like
I was like that that scene didn't add anything
really except the information are you talking
about exactly it's the one where they were
like walking through a market and he was like
trying to convince her to like go with him
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I get what you're saying
um I mean I didn't mind it I thought it was
weird but it was weird why didn't you like
it I just felt like it was it didn't fit with
the rest of the movie like there was nothing
funny about it it was like very expositional
but then that could have been like cut out
and I think it still would have been cool
well you see they had that you said expositional
they have that joke and so that's what I mean
that's the kind of Comedy that this one is
it's I do like it it calls itself aware yeah
it's so self-aware and and it's way more it's
way more self-aware than the other ones yes
um bio by a large margin and so I I think
that I appreciate that yeah so that's what
I mean by how it all I keep saying it that's
why I mean when my time I got to that finale
on the phone like okay this whole movie subtly
makes sense to me and things really do make
or break a movie they really do like
um also can I just point out I wore a Twilight
shirt specifically because Anna Kendrick was
in Twilight and also her name's Bella and
this is about the Bellas so that was smart
irony you're a clever clever woman
well guys what do you think of Sally's shirt
where would you rank Pitch Perfect three leave
in the comments what you would pitch for Pitch
Perfect for ooh I want it to be like a Logan
like it's a super dower Oh I thought you meant
Logan Lerman I got really excited no no one
thinks of Logan Lerman I do no one thinks
of Wolverine and uh follow Sally on YouTube
where she's youtubing it and hey thank you
all for being here on this journey uh I love
when we can complete a franchise and uh I'm
happy that this one ended on a way that I
personally thought was a high note so yes
the kind of Comedy you get here real reasons
alrighty guys Sally say bye to the audience
peace out
foreign